how is it possible to have existence
from non-existence such as the Big Bang
Theory an explosion from nothing before
I get into that let me start off with a
quote by the late Alan Watts what you
are basically deep deep down far far in
is simply the fabric and structure of
existence itself think about how deep
that is that means everything your body
your house the air you breathe your
thoughts alone your awareness your free
will are all part of the source that
existence itself is you your existence
which means that you are the universe
you are of the source and getting away
from religious beliefs I mean I say
myself that I'm not religious that
nature's my church love is my religion
what is love where does that belong in
this nihilistic view of something from
nothing I mean I've heard some people
say that all love is probably just it's
just a chemical reaction that's it no
that doesn't fall in line with nature at
all it shouldn't if anything you'd say
it slows down nature and strongest
survive and other things I've mentioned
this in other videos another interesting
thing to think about is our bodies we're
made up of dozens and dozens of elements
and I've talked about this in other
videos and I've got some real
interesting responses you know I've said
that you know we come from dirt which I
say is a figure of speech and some
people disagree I didn't come from dirt
well actually the human bodies there
shares many different elements that
you'll find in common soil in fact just
to touch on this if you haven't seen me
talk about this in other videos
I mean we're made up of so many
different elements and this includes
metals our iron in our blood copper and
cobalt in our bodies that you cannot be
alive without and although they're
minuscule you know measured in parts per
million it's there you wouldn't be alive
without this smashed together infused
system of energy and atoms I mean this
energy that gives off life to the
universe effortlessly and endlessly that
death implies life and life implies
death it's just a circle the cycle it's
amazing and we get too caught up in
definitions and again I'm not anti
science I've said this before I mean I
think science is wrong about a number of
things just like we've been proving this
route
stree that they're wrong and we learn
new things all the time that's great
we're also right about a lot of things
too we've learned a lot but when we get
caught up in definitions it distracts
from the nature and the awesomeness of
what we're experiencing guys think about
this how do you have nothing non
existence into existence and this
reminds me of a quote from the Dao de
Jing and I'll loosely paraphrase it
actually is what I'm gonna do a Wiseman
knows that there are limits to his
knowledge that there are some things
that you cannot know where a foolish man
thinks he knows everything well I mean
that is just absolute truth there are
for some reason the human brain cannot
fathom this because think about it like
if you want to talk about God for an
example I don't like to use the word God
because a lot of people too many people
I'd say get caught up in this you know
figure in the sky with a beard floating
in this clouds and many many other
people don't feel that way but I mean
this of course would raise the question
okay well what created God okay like it
says end the cycle of okay if there's a
big bang
then what's caused the big bang what was
the nature of that cause right so it
just keeps going forever and ever
because what caused the cause or the
ability to cause the Big Bang total mind
[ __ ] right excuse my language but I mean
ultimately when you think about it it's
clearly something we're not meant we
cannot know if you have the universe
which is made up of all this this
explosion of energy and here we are and
we're able to realize and think for
ourselves that we do exist I mean when
you troubleshoot it at its root core I
would say the most logical explanation
besides the fact that we just can't
understand it is that we're all part of
this consciousness that is experiencing
itself because when you think about the
illusion of our lives that this we
understand that we're a make up of atoms
and you're just this blob together like
I said of energy what is that about so
this actually ties me into the
simulation theory which I don't exactly
agree with because a lot of people get
carried away with it and it seems to
exclude the loving nature of ourselves
and that the actual experience we're
having like I don't identify that we're
part of some computer system that's
plugged in and it takes away from love I
should say which is this unexplainable
mysterious awesomeness that to me proves
the divineness of our existence when I
say divineness that I would say that
we're all it so if you believe in a god
then you are god I would say and a lot
of people when they hear that for the
first time they don't like it I mean
think about it though we can create
languages like you can make your own
language tomorrow if you wanted to just
assign different sounds to different
meanings tada you have a language you
can create a heaven or hell on earth
experience for anyone you have a kid
treat them really good or have a kid and
treat them horribly make their existence
horrible and vice versa think about this
we have free will and we have awareness
of our free will so when you really
think about that I would argue that we
are all gods I'm not saying we're the
god again a lot of people get caught up
in that they don't like hearing it but I
don't know if there's any other
justifiable explanation for what we are
we are the universe Experion Experion
seing itself if you believe in the Big
Bang well you are the Big Bang just as
Alan Watts has stated think about this
guys this is the biggest mind [ __ ] you
can possibly have I don't like to swear
a lot but for effect you know just how
incredible this is and I encourage
everybody to dig into this for
themselves and buy dig into I mean think
about it spend some quiet time thinking
about what was there before time how
could there ever have been a
non-existent time I mean there has to be
a beginning right but at the same time
what created whatever it was it created
the beginning so is there just there was
no beginning I mean I guess that's
possible but it's hard to wrap your mind
about like what is this about now
ultimately the purpose of this video is
to just get you thinking because a lot
of things I'm discussing here are gonna
tie into other videos in the future guys
this is just the beginning of this
channel I discussed many different
topics and I've been enjoying talking
about ancient human civilization which I
will never stop doing that I mean it's a
lifelong passion that is never going to
end but I'm gonna talk about many many
other different things and one of which
is the spiritual nature of our lives of
our existence it's worthy of far more
attention because I'm telling you it's
secure to so many ills of our lives
whether it's depression or lack of
contentment in our lives which is
thriving unfortunately for a lack of
better word throughout the world people
are really starting to question what
this is about because they're not living
the lives that they feel they were meant
to so I'm gonna wrap this up leave me a
comment let me know what your thoughts
are I'm a very open-minded person I just
want to know the truth as I'm sure all
of you do as well I mean if you put a
button in front of
it says hit this and you get the truth
no matter what it is no matter how bad
it debunks everything I thought I knew
and shreds apart everything and makes me
just feel dumb I want to know boom I'm
pressing that button teach me I want to
know so one of the best ways to do that
is for people to share thoughts and
ideas so leave a comment explore this
topic but I'll leave it at that I'm
Jimmy
this bright insight like and subscribe
and I've many other videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics take care
everybody